كما رحبت القوى المدنيه الموقعه على
الاتفاق الايطالي بالبيان الصادر عن
الناطق باسم القوات المسلحه وقالت ان
البيان حمل رسائل مهمه وايجابيه واضافت ان
ذلك يضع على عاتق اطراف الاتفاق ضروره
اكمال مناقشات المرحله النهائيه في اقرب
فرصه ممكنه بما يؤسس لمرحله انتقاليه
مستقره تقود في نهايتها الى انتخابات حره
ونزيهه وشفافه كما اشاد رئيس لجنه الاتصال
بقوى الحريه والتغيير مجموعه المجلس
المركزي
ما ورد في البيان وقال في تغريده على
تويتر ان قوى الحريه والتغيير مجموعه
المجلس المركزي تامل وتسعى لتحقيق توافق
كل الاطراف المعنيه من اجل التعجيل
بالوصول الى اتفاق نهائي يضع حدا للازمه
السياسيه في البلاد ويسترد مسار التحول
الديمقراطي عبر سلطه مدنيه تمثل ثوره
ديسمبر وتعمل على تنفيذ اهدافها حسب
تعبيره